right now relatives of a black man shot
and killed by sheriff's deputies in
north carolina
are now releasing an independent autopsy
that shooting happened while police were
arresting andrew brown jr on a felony
drug charge
the fbi has now also opened a federal
civil rights investigation
michael george has the results of that
independent autopsy
lawyers for the family of andrew brown
jr revealed the results of an
independent autopsy of his death it was
a kill shot
to the back of the head sheriff's
deputies in north carolina were serving
brown with a warrant on felony drug
charges last wednesday
they shot him as he tried to drive away
on monday his family viewed a small
amount of body camera footage
it was just a horrific scene a horrific
video
family members say the video shows brown
had his hands on the steering wheel at
the time
they're demanding the release of the
entire video they won't release the
video
so painstakingly we have to keep putting
the pieces of the puzzle together
brown's death has led to days of
protests and demands for justice in
elizabeth city
the pasco tank county sheriff's
department says officials have filed a
motion
to release the footage which needs a
judge's authorization
we will comply with the judge's daughter
those people who claim the sheriff's
office has the ability
to release either don't know north
carolina law or they are trying to
purposely inflame
a tragic situation the sheriff's
department is urging patients
while state investigators look into the
case michael george cbs
news new york